what do we want
outside Production Studios across the
country
thousands of writers have stepped away
from their keyboards to form picket
lines better pay better residuals uh
larger writers rooms
here in Los Angeles wga president
Meredith steam joined protesters outside
of Netflix Studios they need to fix the
model that they've broken and until they
do we're going to be here we're going to
be on strike Cynthia Littleton is the
co-editor-in-chief of variety and author
of TV on strike she says a prologue
strike would mean writers lose their
jobs as Studio shift production to
unscripted content the studios are going
to lose a lot of money on having to
scramble they're going to have to shut
down shows that they thought they were
going to produce there is going to be
pain all around